[Music]
earlier this morning in Los Angeles
police were involved in a high-speed
chase with a suspect who was drawing a
crowd by throwing money out the window
did you see that throwing money out the
window now folks is it me or is it is
Mitt Romney getting desperate
just hurry
[Applause]
[Music]
it worked though yeah yeah he's way up
in LA now who's excited about the iPhone
5 you happy about this who's booing
somebody that realizes their phone that
they have now is a piece of crap
yeah exactly I just got the iPhone 4 no
today Apple unveiled the iPhone 5 which
is 20% lighter and 18% thinner yeah in
fact it's just a piece of paper that
says you saps will buy anything you'd
still line up for it you know you would
it's a piece of paper I don't care my
new character that's iPhone 5 guy that's
good else is going on yesterday Bill
Clinton said that President Obama helped
him edit his convention speech the
biggest change was that Obama had
Clinton used the phrase Americans
instead of all you fine honeys
there's a weird story the company that
made the Tupac hologram remember the
Tupac hologram the company that made the
Tupac hologram is filing for bankruptcy
yeah
the announcement was made by company
spokesperson Elvis Presley weird story
free for a few hours yesterday the Sears
online catalog featured a model whose
nipple was showing yeah it was the first
time in years someone saw something in a
Sears catalog they actually wanted in a
new interview Blake Lively said that if
she could she would have 30 kids yeah
read all about it in the October issue
of I've never had a baby so I'm talking
out of my ass magazine
[Applause]
no woman who's had a kid once 30 that
was fantastic 29 more times and I'm done
want to hear a Hollywood rumor good
that's two of you legally legally I can
proceed the latest rumor in Hollywood is
that Lindsay Lohan has been hospitalized
for walking pneumonia yeah
doctors doctors say no one should start
worrying until Lohan comes down with
driving pneumonia the problem in Russia
eight one hundred and twenty two year
old man has passed away and he credited
his long life to abstaining from alcohol
tobacco and women his his last words
were I've made a huge mistake
[Applause]
what's the point of being 122 no more
oatmeal yeah I want out at 40 if that's
the case and someday I'll get there I'm
22 the Octomom you all remember the
optimum the optimum says she has made
enough money from porn to buy a house
enough money from porn to buy a house
yeah the dilapidated condemned structure
that can hold up to 15 people said she's
happy to finally have her own home
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no after a pause
like that it's good just to leave it
alone to wait like that and then go you
look sad let's hope you get it any of
the condemned condemned dilapidated
structure that can hold 15 people you
think it's gonna be what right the the
house yes but it wasn't it was there it
was the ahkamaat exactly that's that's
known as the old switcheroo that's
Koko's switcheroo steep oh yeah you
didn't realize how funny that joke was
it's a good thing I'm here that's plenty